[Music]
we're just asking the the talent through
send this decision because ultimately if
they don't the consequences and there
are severe consequences will will be
borne by the mothers and children of
Afghanistan
[Music]
thank you
to have access to women and children you
need to have female health staff and so
if you don't have female health staff
you don't have access to those to those
people so essentially it's just not
possible for us to do our job if we if
we our female colleagues are not able to
get out there
[Music]
we have complied with all cultural norms
and we simply can't work without our
dedicated female staff who are essential
for us to be able to access women who
are in desperate need of assistance
foreign
[Music]
this comes at the worst possible time
when the economy of Afghanistan is
collapsing and we need women as part of
the workforce to enable the economy to
recover
foreign